each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
good morning everyone I'm glad that then
put me as a second speed up the speaker
this morning it's much better than when
I just had a months ago I was the second
last speaker in the last session on last
day of the conference plus that's a
Saturday you imagine how many attendees
will be there actually it cannot be
quite good in a lot of attendees States
stay there and listen to my vintage ah
da hey just mentioned about the cyber
infrastructure for you know scientific
researchers are and you probably heard a
lot of talks last day but the touch upon
a lot a lot of the mateship on the
biomechanical peckish miself how to
process data again here I'm don't ugly
the same direction but the most
specifically i'm going to give you a a
prodigy from project perspective how can
deal with about you know biological data
set so my topic is the gateway to
biologic pathways it's about how to pull
out the biological pathway data together
this or make it web accessible and also
are going to use enable this to be a
semantic web ex let's not work well
looks like the gauge is now walking i
have to switch over nope nothing works
okay i just stay on this side anyhow
okay here's a my agenda and I didn't
steal this from Simon's slides because
he had the more questions in our hair
those that wh show the beige questions
but I had this in my mind before I
create a slight and those are the
questions I'm going to address why we
are doing this project is and what's the
future direction about this project now
um well I came to several folks
yesterday they asked me about what I'm
doing oh ok i told them that well
i'm walking on by life pathways so what
it the next question is what is biologic
pathways so ah in a short sentence it is
our our current understanding of
biological processes ok I'll show you
how this knowledge can be presented now
think about the way that we can get a
the about life data by our password data
our first probably lot i'm actually
secured from the scientifically ridge
and also our ways the high-throughput
web technologies you have microarrays
you have our mass spectrometers and you
get generate a lot of data and with
those set of data you can use a computer
program to infer the biologic pathways
but again those up has two is actually
hypothetically you can not hundred
percent rascals they did but you have to
think of when you can still sell out
data well what's use of biologic
pathways well hong mentioned last night
actually it's one of the in one of the
in the nih map and actually we mentioned
that biologic pathways as well as the
networks are very important for
biomedical research and you can use this
to formulate hypotheses and you can use
this to verify our lab results and also
are very employment you can share
research outcomes with other you know
scientists in the field now this is a
biologic biologists view of pathways
okay now if you are give you how do I
arguable think this pathway is this is
how it look like I just find this on the
web and just put on my sides and I know
ah it's hard to read the puppets better
than you know physicians prescriptions
right and then those signatures the very
hard to recognize but here you can still
see the you know other the lines you
know edges and different notations but
there are different components that
involve in the biologic pathways well
thanks to the technology now you can
enjoy the house with this way so this is
our brevis from cat
database and you'll see that it's quite
involved overwhelmed because you have so
many items that you are on this diagram
and you'll figure out the different kind
of relationships now this is a different
way of representing the pathways it's
from a pile psyche the website hosted by
the Stanford Research Institute and
you'll see that the even though we are
talking about biologic pathways but they
were in talk to different people with
different people have different way of
representing T a pathway as one of our
fellow folks from Indiana mammal he
mentioned that the yesterday about the
different ways of representing this past
week data so it's kind of interesting
field in the Empire informatics feel now
well how many databases out here well
there is a list part of our biologic
pathways resource list and it's over
right now there are over 80 pairs with
either basis well compared to a lot of
that it is still very small fraction of
the entire biological biology Ariz now
well those databases that way is
different interests different focus
different labs may have different into
some specific projects and they all have
different representations and they all
use different target formats and also
they all use different access method and
well coverage you will be different as
well now for by artists to dress any
intriguing crashings lot of time they
have to occur multiple databases and in
order to get some answers to their
questions well well that's a very common
practice for them not the challenges
they don't have any unified in
interfaces for occurring the databases
and they have to go through different
databases and use different ways to do
carry the division and the past most
important thing is that right now
everybody has web presence well that's
good from all the days you'll have those
tax base to you know database you do
curry
very challenging for biologists but now
everybody has a web presence old that's
good way for biologists it's right it's
very easy for human eyes to use the web
but you know in terms of let the
computers to process this everything
embedded in the HTML documents are going
to be very difficult to process because
HTML pretty much is the standard for our
it's a protocol for formatting the
content not really for composing or
storing the content so it's not machine
possible now I give you a scenario here
about how to use different data sets in
biomedical research for example if la if
a biologist is interesting some enzymes
in a metabolic pathway he may find that
those enzymes actually are translated
form some jeans okay now and then later
on he may find that all those treat
those jeans they actually are regulated
by summing transfect transaction
factories well further search may
indicate that adults transferred
construction factors may relate when we
triggered by some cell surface receptors
now located here I have three sets of
our past week data and they are related
this is a challenge that other
biologists will have and how to you know
go through the search process to find
the right information they want and one
of the speakers mentioned yesterday that
the four scientists be experiencing
problem of inflammation explosion they
have so much information to process and
you have too many many data are too much
data to digest to absorb so what I'm
going to divide this project is to well
I'm not going to integrate all those
data sets together it's going to be very
challenging for us to do this now well a
lot of data are there okay a lot of data
sets out there but the challenge is no
unified interface to access to you well
second is this relates to the biological
database integration
it's everything's we have had Jim bank
or other databases and the database
integration has been a very challenging
research area for a lot of folks out
there and they tried so many different
ways to achieve this I think we're not
we're still not there yet ah well want
me to do integration is to develop some
common schemas I know it's very China
for them in different research group
have different interests and also
different domain have different way of
representing knology so it's very
difficult to do this and our again I'm a
federal folks at the iu mammal mentioned
it yesterday that it well when you do
integration you should not do this on
bison syntax okay you have to do this at
semantic level you have to do this by
meanings okay otherwise you can end up
with something that's not a not so
useful for biologists for biomedical
researchers now so this project is about
creating a portal for biological pass
with the SS okay now what we're going to
do is we're gonna support a semantical a
but there are lot of talks about as many
web in life sciences w3c actually had a
workshop last year about you know
semantical semantic will happen in life
sciences a lot i'm actually a research
study nobody really had a some extra
data you can access online because i
mean when you talk about semantic
already talked about the web of data and
we've been talking about bad we talked
about oh I web right so I mean if
everything is stored on your local hard
disk well this probably will if you to
prove yourself semantic web anyhow now
we're going to use power packs format
I'll get into bio packs little later
backpacks actually is standard for our
common pass we format okay I guess I'm
lucky to find some you know common
background common ground that every can
agree upon ways and I want this to be
accessible from through the HTTP GET if
you are familiar with semantics that
where you probably noticed everything
every interest
having the Semantic Web extra will be
Weber resources so hiding access to data
still having the best way to do this is
the HTTP protocol and the with semantic
linkages the data are we present here
Paul will be able to link two different
external databases now and i also want
to support the xml server based web
service i know i should not put the xml
sober but that when you talk web
servicing the bioinformatics landscape a
community and you'll notice that not
everybody all have the same definition
of web services okay the only see the
web services became in different things
so I did I did it on purpose such as XML
supper bass the web services and once we
support which will provided data and
then by you know Wow info magicians from
all the labs can just create the ulnar
rendering and you'll see there's so many
different ways to present the about past
with data and they can do whatever they
want to do and another important thing
is we try to let different platform our
implementations to consumer the data as
well because a lot of laughs out there
in the biomedical about you from Eric
field are using Apple using linux unix
but so they'll still want to access the
data and also important for us is to
provide a unit unified interface for
current has we datasets and now this
project not going to take care of the
data training issues because this I had
rather to do is verifying all the eggs
the data from experiments and also we're
not generating a new data in this parts
as well now so what is about packs ok
Bob packs is the is a standard that
developed by a group of researchers in
University at a university as well as
the pharmaceutical industries okay those
folks actually are the experts in the
field
for biological pathways the they created
a consortium called bio pathway
consortiums the define this projects
being several years I think about two or
three years ongoing process they have
very good discipline in keeping up with
monthly meetings in the publishing
minutes online and you can go there and
take a look at what what they do and and
they define about pax ontology okay it
pretty much just defined the the
energies in the biologic pathways as
well as their relationships they had a
vision about semantic web and so they
create this using owl it's a web
ontology language that's uh see also the
three WC recommendation style if you can
take a look out there and uh well
another interesting thing about this on
how do you that it's in XML format
unlike largest it's just you know this
text texture descriptive document about
downhearted but this one is XML document
so you can pretty much use it to process
that you can use it as a schema to valid
a lot of documents and that this is the
levels of like pathways could you cannot
accomplish everything at one time so
they have to do this power levels first
level is about metabolic pathways it's
official release last year and I think I
lastly aurélie this year and tiled area
you can use the hey what website out
there you can just point to the URL and
look at the Untied also you can download
it on your machine in case you want to
some local prosthetic and the second
level actually is still in Kenya trees
too and it's all right on their web and
you can take a look at it's about
molecular interaction networks as well
level three as far as signaling pathways
also they have two more levels are on
the road map and you can take a look at
their website now this is how are the
foil packs on Taj erotic well it
probably were familiar with of your own
problem
this looks like a and the UML for the
bar by PacSun Hodge and on top we have
entities and this is the decal new class
and actually every inherits from the
entity and you have dem cunning
interactions also you may have a pathway
and you may have some you know physical
entities can be a complex can be RNA or
small mark use the proteins and among
other things also here you probably
notice that they don't just define all
the physical and it is they also define
those are abstract and it is well like a
reaction it's a process it's not
necessarily the the physical energy you
can patch you can feel and I didn't show
you the other part ana paula actually is
called a utility class actually is
enough set of you know classic see they
relate to the biologic pathways here is
the example of what you actually see in
past week class so you have those they
call it the slots awesome technical
properties but you know object aren't
programming probably called attributes
those are the attributes those are
common attributes in here from entities
those are the specific ones that for
their pathways so those are kind of
things they already find it in the
ontology and you can use this to
validate your the data so here's what we
propose to do are we have a system on
there will process the data they will
store data in tannoy in Val packs format
because we don't want the conversion
transformation one more time so and we
also have the query engine delve through
the data from our internal storage and
well there are several ways to get data
you can get data from those hats with
their base hosts and you can download it
from there and I just process we have
data source components they actually
process different set data and also we
we thought about using the web service
care provides web service to access
their password data but not in the
ballpark format
and the were used by packs on target to
transform sought the data from the
associates and then installing our
internal persistent storage this is
where we store the about packs format
data they are in XML format and we also
provide web server have a query engine
they'll appear the story the data is
stored in the persistent storage and
also we have web service that every can
query our HTTP access method actually
using the web services to accomplish
this and then we can create all kinds of
client applications without groupism
created all with other you know
interested biomet empower some
implementations want to create they can
also access their work our web services
to do to data and create their own
application to rent their own oops skip
too fast so I have a few more slides
yeah aah sorry aah now this is what we
do with our internal data store it
pretty much everything is the XML format
and well larger data said compared to
the others of course it's all relative
small but when we talk about a lot of
the XS for example are if you look at a
data set from biopsych for each organism
and you have a very large xml document
and we tried to process the foul and
with different kind of technologies and
now the memory walk quite well because
uh the issue is about the memory because
you can a lot of eczema passers cannot
hold them much data into the memory and
we sought about different strategies to
solve the problem and one thing came out
was from my experience with a technology
microsoft a record or web storage system
in the exchange server 2000 i don't know
how many of you are aware of this
technology but actually the technology
was stayed over our actual ahead of time
at time that the everything you could do
with web storage system in the XML even
though it has the ADL components out
there and you can access but what's
behind it is in XML format you can
create a ski making the
our structure you can do everything in
XML so awesome I had this idea and then
I went to the attacker and met Michael
Reese I don't know whether he's here
today I sent him email yesterday and I
hope oh he's it but in the back he had
good we had a talk at the conference and
I just want to know about the XML
support and XML in dl like in the sequel
server to solid five and we had a child
and he remind me to his presentation in
the varsity optic the attacker actually
I learned a lot from him and we had a
female communication going on about how
to solve our problem but anyhow I mean
we look at it in we're looking to the
XML data type in the sequel server 2005
it looks likes very promising technology
for us and our job is how to put data in
there and the in with the smell data
type what you could do is you can put
the different kinds of XML document you
don't have to have the document with
same schema okay I'm talking about the
same same column so that's a beauty of
doing that because we can simplify our
query queries so and we just decide to
put the you know those small entities in
the XML data type column we have passed
we have small molecules we havenae then
we have proteins we can plaudits in the
in the xml data type corner and also are
the sequel server 2005 support indexing
on the xml data type even though it's
prob data type is still support the
index and another beauty by using a
sequel services on five is supposed to
xml the xquery michael is the expert on
the expiry and he wrote up a lot of
articles and the votes on this square so
we're using the xperia technology for
our application as well and the in order
to get different energies you can just
call it a
you can just you know perform almost
multiple carriers to get to those
entities and actually this really helped
us to eliminate the complexity of design
very sophisticated database schema
otherwise you have to use different
technology to achieve this now it's
working now ah this is how the one of
the pathway entity will look like in the
database it's pretty much like this
acceptor that we have namespaces for all
this because the we install the data xml
data in the xml arm data type color you
have have have namespace there so this
is what you look like at you and all you
don't see the low level d topes
low-level details are there because like
for example password components actually
is made up of all you know interaction
steps and then you can look at different
in the participants in the interaction
steps to find what kind of what are what
kind of a biological elements are
component that involved in the pathways
now ah this is our website out there I i
wish i could be some demo and after i
talk talk to there and i decided not to
do the challenges that i have to use now
Microsoft Technology it's not just
something we deal with Microsoft it's
that the little decryption isn't likes
of technology that we have to use the
Firefox I don't think this laptop has
the Firefox to do this but uh this our
website you can go there and take a look
and we hell quite comprehensive
documents and about how to access our
data set there and you can use web
services you can use HTTP GET
postmasters to access our data and again
like any other Microsoft web services
you have whistle file you can just
consume the way you want and for those
who are not familiar is web services we
provide documentation on how to use this
with Java with a shoe shop a couple of
my students actually excellent job on
this they spent a lot of time writing
the documentation and the
now what about future okay well we we
probably out providing data now but we
don't have any way to consumer data to
visualize data so our next step will be
reading a client application to
consumers the eval packs format data
I'll initial global to criticisms in
c-sharp well the reason for this is that
we are thinking about the large about
informatics community development using
Mac using using linux unix your honor
that C sharp prints on those boxes to no
clue no yeah mullen project actually
yeah dr. ray thank you yeah he's the
only one who's no dance that's why i was
thinking using the unfortunately a
mountain party actually has not been
able to provide support for wing form
class so we're not be able to do this at
this moment I think I'll pebble which is
you know Goa with our initial goal so I
will pursue a different approach to do
that and the linkages to external data
it's already there all you have to do
just will find how to access different
and data sets out there for example
genebank i'm actually on tree has
utility it's a web search they provide
web services you can access their data
set so any literature area in his
reference in the past which actually can
be accessed from the entree he utility
web service and also i was thinking
about how to update the data sets from
you know external on data sources and
last to powell help us to do you know
semantic data mining as well as
machinery reasoning cuz everything is in
the machine processable format all you
have to try the coded to process data
and write a coded to process the data i
like to stand microsoft research force a
part of this project and also smt i like
to check them for his his walk to
provide all kinds of supported we need
for this project now I collaborator
soon from biology department of our
campers and actually he's working on
really radiofrequency effect on human
cells actually very interesting project
sponsored by Air Force what they are
doing is they are doing in there can be
conducting research on how the radio
frequency can affect our human and the
what they use the rich video frequency
they use actually are the ones that you
yourself industry uses so you think that
they will help potential impact on how
cell phone will affect our health and 11
points in they are looking at is they
look in different pathways so as one of
the pathways approaches and they know
that they try to find out whether that
you know any radio frequency will affect
cell death and also they have so much
data in from the microarray experiment
they really want to look at a different
pathways how those cells are those jeans
different you know biological components
payrolls in the to the external external
disturbance from the radio frequencies
and also like to thank my students who
worked real hard on this project and I
like to entertain some questions if you
shy to answer questions you can send a
question to me so this email and again
this is our website and already
encouraged ever to go there and take a
look at and the consumer our data and
give our comments back and we like to
see you no more use of this web portal
nope anybody
her
oh well yeah well actually we tried
dinner first okay jenna is the one that
we tried in it well the i mentioned that
the xml parser issues because we can now
handle this a large amount data because
the way that initially we look at the
power packs a bio psych data and it's in
large xml document and there's no way
you can load into the xml internal
memory yeah and also we look at the
tiffany and well my students oh yeah
sequels dope yeah the Civil oops quite
well it's just beautifully and we tried
to deceive them as well yeah okay sorry
yeah arms and usefulness the day
it sounds like they put forward senator
yeah this is an effort to group actually
already publicly looking on the level to
data so that hopefully before i open an
important see into our system until it
will be provided to the bioinformatics
community
as I read
construction why yeah yeah we can do
that with our client it depends to set
as as memo mentioned that there's so
many different ways to rent the graphic
you know graphic representation of the
pathways it depends on your research
focus it depends on how you can solve
your problem sanitizing solution right I
agree with me a very good point it's
another you know commuter effort to
standardize this I think it's not there
yet okay